نعم ، لقد رأينا قبل شهرين أن
السفن الروسية أرادت السفن الروسية
الدخول إلى
المنطقة التي توجد بها حدائق طاحونة هولندية في
بحر الشمال
بهدف معرفة كيف يتم تشغيل هيكل التحكم المشترك
لمزارع الطاحونة الهوائية هذه.
كان تهديدًا ، لذلك أرسلنا
البحرية وخفر السواحل لمرافقة هذه
السفينة الروسية ، ولذا غادروا
المنطقة ، كانت هذه هي المرة الأولى التي رأينا فيها
سفينة روسية تدخل منطقة
مزارع الطواحين للقيام
باستطلاعها.  خطير للغاية
بالطبع ولكن في مجال الإنترنت ، نرى
هجمات متعددة على أساس يومي تقريبًا
لاقتحام السفارات الهولندية أو
تجاه القوات المسلحة من أجل
مصلحتهم ، لذا فهذه إحدى
وظائفنا هي التأكد من أنهم
لم تنجح في spirionizing
نعم على البنية التحتية الحيوية
لهولندا